hey that that is not a pro-life position
by any stretch of the imagination but
Trump he just he's muddled on this and
the line that he said that really got
everybody going he wasn't just
criticizing DeSantis for six weeks and
again you might think six weeks is too
much you might think six weeks is too
far
but Trump called the heartbeat bills
terrible he used the word terrible there
terrible the Sanctus was willing to sign
a five-week and six-week bench did you
support that you think that I think what
he did is a terrible thing and a
terrible mistake and as the guy that is
supposedly the most pro-life president
ever and gets credit for bringing in a
court that then did overturn Roe v Wade
which was not a constitutional right
abortion it was a state's right issue he
gets credit for that the idea that he
would say that a heartbeat bill is
terrible well a lot of people are
hitting him on that here's another guy
from The Daily wire here's Ben Shapiro
Donald Trump
did a mainstream media interview over
the weekend uh it didn't go amazing for
him his his recent interviews have not
been going particularly well this one
was with Kristen Welker the most
newsworthy thing that he said in this
interview
was he made a comment suggesting that
heartbeat bills like to protect the
lives of The Unborn in states are
terrible which is not only not pro-life
it's an awful thing to say it's one
thing to say that tactically speaking as
presidents of the United States I'm
going to try to reach as much consensus
as possible and gradually move the line
back on abortion to accustom the
American people to protecting life
because if we move too far too fast then
the Snapback is going to be dramatic as
we saw in Kansas that's a that's a
pragmatic question and it's the case you
can make that's not what Trump says what
Trump actually says about abortion in
this interview is morally egregious he
says that heartbeat bills to you know
protect babies in the womb past week
five week six those are terrible that's
the thing he says a terrible thing and a
terrible mistake and Terror in the state
he's not even talking federally in the
state
hey that that is not a pro-life position
by any stretch of the imagination all
right look everything Ben said there was
right
I disagree with Ben on what public
policy should be related to abortion and
you can watch old videos of ours from
probably now seven years ago debating
abortion I've shifted a little bit and
that I I actually think even 15 weeks is
probably a bit far you could probably
push it closer to 12 weeks but I
absolutely believe in exceptions and
okay we can again as I always say we can
always talk about all of those things
but we will never make everybody happy
but Ben is is completely right there on
the equivocation that Trump is doing but
somehow this has been terrible it
doesn't it doesn't really make sense so
all Trump's position that is so all we
can really do in the midst of all of
this it's all going to get weirder and
crazier as you know this election year
rolls out and we're still we're still 12
months no we're still 14 months
basically away from the general general
election God help us all so all we can
do in the midst of all of that is is
tell the truth to the best of our
ability and let the chips fall where
they may